ya hemos hablado de las derivadas
parciales de una función de varias
variables y también hemos visto cómo
calcular las e interpretarlas en
términos de gráficas lo que quiero hacer
ahora es dar una definición formal y
sólo sólo para recordar esto es algo que
se aplica para funciones con varias
entradas verdad
digamos podríamos tener si en variables
aquí de entrada que se yo podría ser
muchísimas verdad y creo que es bueno
retomar la analogía para el caso de una
dimensión así que pensemos cómo se
define la derivada con una variable muy
bien entonces pensemos en alguna función
digamos que tenemos f x f x que sea como
siempre nuestro ejemplo clásico x
cuadrada y nosotros pensamos en quién
sería la derivada de nuestra función con
respecto a x verdad entonces vamos a
pintar un plano aquí tenemos el eje
vertical el eje horizontal en el eje
vertical pondremos efe x y nosotros
sabemos qué
se ve más o menos así es como una es una
parábola de hecho
más o menos se ve así entonces para
calcular la derivada de la función
necesitamos especificar en donde vamos a
calcular la verdad esto depende de qué
punto digamos en qué punto estamos
localizados entonces digamos que nos
encontramos en este punto a verdad y la
idea de calcular esta derivada es tomar
un pequeño paso digamos en la dirección
x verdad que vamos a denotar como de
equis verdad y luego vemos que tanto
influye esto en la función verdad es
decir que tanto cambia la función al
haber hecho esta pequeña variación
verdad y en esencia lo que tenemos que
hacer ahora es calcular la pendiente
verdad de la línea que conecta estos dos
puntos es decir tenemos que calcular la
la proporción que hay entre df y de x
que por eso es muy conveniente utilizar
la anotación de la aemet es verdad
entonces si nosotros por ejemplo a este
de x le llamamos h verdad que es un
número que va a ser muy
entonces tendremos por aquí abajo h y
acá arriba tendremos la variación que
hay con efe verdad entonces tendremos
efe de a más h que es cuánto vale la
función al habernos movido tantito a la
derecha verdad y le restamos lo que
teníamos anteriormente esto nos da que
tanto cambió la función verdad y ahora
en realidad no queremos tomarnos una h
particular sino queremos cada vez
tomarnos h es más pequeñas y por eso es
que tomamos un límite cuando h tiende a
cero y esto es lo que significa tomar
los pasos cada vez más más y más
pequeños verdad ahora en el mundo de
varias variables tenemos una historia
similar y lo que vamos a hacer es tomar
una fracción en digamos en donde h será
un pequeño paso en alguna dirección por
ejemplo en este caso en la dirección x
verdad entonces por ejemplo tomemos por
supuesto hay que decir dónde vamos a
evaluar esto verdad digamos que
evaluamos en él
digamos que tenemos sólo dos entradas y
vemos quién sería esta derivada parcial
bueno nuevamente hagamos un cociente
verdad de cómo cambia nuestra función al
hacer un pequeño cambio este pequeño
cambio en la dirección x vamos a
llamarle nuevamente h verdad y si por
ejemplo lo vemos todo esto en el espacio
de entradas aquí tendremos nuestro
espacio de entradas que es el espacio es
un plano el plano xy y digamos que aquí
ubicamos nuestro punto a b este es el
punto y coma b
entonces nuestra h en esencia es una una
pequeña desviación una pequeña
desviación en la dirección x sería
nuestro de bueno aquí pues tenemos como
parcial de x verdad nuestro cambio en x
que también podríamos llamar h verdad y
es lo que tenemos justamente aquí y como
ya hemos visto anteriormente
digamos la idea de tener una función que
nos mande este
espacio de entradas a este otro espacio
de salidas que en este caso es la recta
verdad aquí tendremos efe y digamos
quizás por aquí cae aquí tendremos la
imagen de este punto ya en el espacio de
salida es verdad entonces esta pequeña
variación en la dirección x nos da una
variación en en ene efe verdad sería
nuestra parcial de f verdad y entonces
lo que queremos hacer es calcular esta
diferencia verdad la diferencia de
cuando teníamos efe de a más h efe de a
más h que es nuestra pequeña variación y
la segunda coordenada se quedó fijada
verdad esa no la hemos movido y queremos
ver cómo cambia con respecto al punto
original verdad sería efe de b
ve
esto y nuevamente no queremos cualquier
h si no queremos hacer que esta h se
vuelva cada vez más y más pequeña es
decir que este pequeño brinco se haga
más chico más chico más chico y entonces
estamos calculando esta proporción
verdad significa que estamos tomando
estamos aproximando por cambios cada vez
más y más pequeños e iu y esta sería
nuestra definición formal de la derivada
parcial de nuestra función con respecto
a la variable x y solo para practicar
vamos a tratar de hacer exactamente lo
mismo pero para nuestra variable y vamos
a quitar toda esta parte que hicimos
para el caso en una dimensión verdad que
ya deberíamos estar muy familiarizados
con el que vamos a quitar esto
y retomemos entonces cuál sería la
definición para la derivada parcial de
nuestra función pero ahora con respecto
a la variable y la derivada parcial de
a la variable i y como siempre estaremos
pensando evaluando esto en algún punto
particular verdad entonces como como
calcularemos esto ahora lo que vamos a
tener es una pequeña variación pero en
la dirección y acá tendremos nuestra
nuestra pequeña variación y esto pues
nos inducir a alguna variación en la
función f verdad entonces vamos a hacer
vamos a hacer el cociente de la
variación ene efe y en el denominador
tendremos nuestro pequeño incremento en
la variable y que de hecho también vamos
a denotar con h verdad entonces aquí
tendremos h
'hemos h en el denominador y ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es calcular
efe de verdad la variable x se queda
constante entonces aquí es a coma b y
aquí sí tenemos un incremento más h y
luego restamos lo que valía la función
en el punto original
efe
como ve muy bien y nuevamente no
queremos una h particular sino queremos
hacer que estas desviaciones sean cada
vez más y más pequeñas
entonces aplicamos el límite cuando h
tiende a cero verdad y por supuesto aquí
en vez de h podríamos haber puesto del
talle o pudimos haber puesto otra letra
en realidad no importa quién hayamos
puesto verdad el punto es que está este
numerito o esta constante se vaya
haciendo cada vez más y más pequeña así
que esta es la definición formal para
una derivada parcial es muy parecida al
caso de una dimensión pero yo lo que
siempre hago para tratar de recordarlo
es tratar de de comprender qué significa
esta digamos parcial de f esta parcial
de x o parcial de y que en esencia es
recuperar la notación de la verdad
estamos viendo pequeños cambios en cada
uno de ellos y es bueno siempre tener en
mente esto puede ser algo útil sobre
todo digamos a medida que introduzcamos
nuevas nociones y tipos de derivadas
como
la derivada direccional y creo que
ayudará a entender qué es lo que pasa en
ciertos contextos bueno aquí terminamos
este vídeo nos vemos en el próximo